Mindy Grossman has spent
her professional life
thinking about what we want to
buy and how we want to feel.
From fashion with Tommy
Hilfiger and Ralph Lauren,
to Nike with Phil Knight,
and the Home Shopping
Network with Barry Diller,
she's worked alongside
some of the most innovative
and iconoclastic
entrepreneurs of our time,
constantly pushing herself just
beyond what was comfortable.
I don't believe I've truly been 100% ready
for any job I've ever taken.
Now she's got arguably her biggest job
and the biggest challenge of her career.
WeightWatchers, which
Grossman has rebranded WW,
is more than a company.
It's a way of life, a state of mind
and maybe exactly the
sort of tricky, messy,
human-focused endeavor she's
been preparing for all along.
Add in to those challenges,
in the past year, she's
faced a global pandemic
and some harsh criticism
over some of her decisions.
I spoke with Mindy to find out
what a career squarely focused
on bringing your true
feelings and experiences
can tell us about the changing
role of the modern leader.
I think too many women have felt
that they don't put themselves out there
because they have to wait to be perfect.
First of all, I'm so grateful
to you for doing this
and opening up your home virtually to me.
Originally you set out to be a lawyer,
or that's what you thought
you were gonna do, true?
Absolutely.
From the time I was a little girl
watching Perry Mason with my grandmother,
I was convinced that I
wanted to be a lawyer,
and actually ultimately a judge.
I'm an adopted child.
And when I was about four or five,
I had to go into the court
and there was a judge.
It actually happened to be a female judge,
which was unusual at that time.
And I remember going up to her
and she affirmed that I was
gonna be with my parents.
And I said, I wanna be
someone that can have
that kind of impact on people.
And that was gonna be my approach.
And I was an English literature
and philosophy major,
planning to go to law
school in the fall of '78.
But I made the pretty radical decision.
And remember calling
my parents and I said,
"I've decided not to go to law school
"and I'm leaving right now
and I'm moving to New York."
And I think that moment was defining
because I realized for a fact
that not having taken that risk
would actually have been riskier
than taking the risk
and redefining my path.
And so you end up not a lawyer.
You end up in the menswear
business for quite some time.
Like, that's where you start out.
Was that purposeful or
was that just the job
that was available?
Because you make your way
through that leg of the business
pretty dramatically and pretty quickly.
Yeah, when I first moved to New York,
I had an interview at a big
multi-brand menswear conglomerate.
Actually, at the time, there
weren't very many women
in the menswear business.
And I went to work for the president
of the international division
of the menswear side of the company.
And that really set me up on the course
of then staying in the menswear industry
for over 15 years.
I worked for Ron Chereskin, Jeffrey Banks,
then Merona Sport.
Then I had the opportunity
to work for Willi Smith,
who was an incredible designer in the 80s
who really believed in culture
driving fashion and change.
Then worked for Tommy Hilfiger
and then Ralph Lauren.
So how does your style develop
working for that series of people?
So I think there's a couple of things
that have defined my leadership style.
One is I pretty much have wholly
worked for entrepreneurs my entire career.
Right.
So I've always had
this intrapreneur curiosity,
passion around what it is I do.
I'd say the second thing
that defined a lot of my leadership style
is I never believed that
I needed to bifurcate
my work life and my personal life.
It's hard enough being one Mindy,
nevertheless trying to be two.
And that was a little
difficult in starting out,
even with a family and being a mom
and being a wife and working,
but I always felt it
made me more accessible
and have more humanity.
And if you look at the pandemic
and what we've been through,
people literally look up to leaders
who are willing to show
themselves and show empathy
and really show care across
all areas of the business,
financial, social, and human.
So one of my favorite things about you,
and full disclosure,
you and I are friends.
I've become friendly with both
you and your husband, Neil.
And one of the fun things that I got to do
is talk to Neil a little bit about you.
So I'm gonna have you
watch something, if we can,
that he told me when I talked to him
and I asked him just to tell a story
that he felt captured your relationship.
You guys have been married
for 33 years.
Should I be nervous?
No, I think you're gonna,
get a kick out of this.
Okay.
We have a phenomenal daughter.
You've met her, I believe.
But she was your
typical-ish 14, 15-year-old.
And she was having
friends for a sleep over
and they were gonna go
party, New York City kids.
And they go out and they're
all dressed to the nines.
One of them comes home
at about 8:30 and says,
I'm a little tired, goes to sleep.
And the rest of them show
up about an hour later.
And it was sort of one of those moments.
And I looked at my wife
and said, "Can I help?"
And her answer was no.
That was probably 9:30.
And she's finished dealing with the issue
at about 12:30 or 1.
And in she comes and
she's sort of steaming,
not so much with them, but me.
And she says, "Some help you are."
And I said, "I don't work for you."
And she looked back and
said, "That's right.
"You would have been
fired a long time ago."
I so remember that moment.
You remember that?
I so remember that.
And the funny part is we are
such opposite human beings.
Neil is a mathematical
physicist at his core
and some of that is black and white.
And, you know, I'm kind of
opposite on the spectrum.
So some of the funniest
times in our marriage
has kind of been laughing
at the differences.
And the one thing he didn't mention,
the second I said, "Yes,
you don't work for me
"because I would fire you,"
we got hysterical laughing.
Yeah.
And there has to be
those moments of tension
that can turn into humor.
That's what life is, right?
Like so many high-powered executives,
the pandemic has kept Mindy in one place,
her home in the Hudson Valley,
north of New York City.
It's a living testament to
her and Neil's eclectic taste,
along with a sense of whimsy.
She gave me a virtual tour.
So every room has its own
different personality.
Ah, there you see him in the sunroom.
Oh, there he is, hard at work.
One of my favorites is this room.
And this is part library.
part dining room,
part art installation.
If I go around, there's
Marilyn, Salvador Dali,
Marie Antoinette, Mick Jagger,
Einstein, Frida Kahlo,
Audrey Hepburn, and Abraham Lincoln.
This is where I've been
working since March.
And you can see the eclectic nature
of our reading and our books.
This is actually Robert the Bruce.
And it actually opens.
And this is Tartan House.
It's been kind of a labor of love
that we've been up here, which
to a degree, it's a gift.
I never would have spent
as much time up here.
So it's been a lot of fun with the family.
All the while, Grossman
has been continuing
a corporate transformation at
WW one Zoom call at a time.
The turnaround hasn't been
easy or universally hailed,
especially by shareholders
who were wildly enthusiastic
and then skeptical.
[Man On TV Commercial] Hey,
Sally, you still on that diet?
Grossman and her team
had the delicate task
of radically reshaping
a brand long associated
simply with dropping pounds.
So I got through the party
without eating one bite of cake.
To an era that has a much
more holistic approach
to living one's best life.
When the company hired Grossman in 2018,
the brand felt antiquated
and candidly out of touch.
Clearly WeightWatchers was a brand
that had been around forever.
But if we were gonna go into the future,
we couldn't just be defined by weight.
I know people laughed at me a little
when I said we are gonna ban the use
of before and after pictures forever
because health is a journey.
And what I want at this point in my life,
and what I need is very
different than what my daughter,
who's a young mom needs.
And today we don't tell
you what you have to weigh.
What we say is, what
does healthy mean to you?
What are your goals and how
do we help you get there?
And that's not about a number on a scale.
Among that sort of reassessment,
how do we think about our wellness?
Because that has all changed as well.
And I wonder how you think about it.
You know, it's interesting.
When I joined the company a
little over three years ago,
we were talking about wellness
and talking about the wellness economy
and the trillions of dollars,
but no one in the world
was getting healthier.
And this pandemic has only
heightened that reality.
And wellness has absolutely gone
from being a luxury to a necessity,
especially if you look at COVID
and the leading indicators
and cause of death around
obesity and diabetes.
I'd say the second thing
that is critical today,
the trust factor around
brands has really heightened.
There's so much misinformation out there.
And if you can be that trusted brand
and that partner for people,
that is a significant opportunity.
And then lastly, if you could build it all
around the power of community
and bring people together
around common values,
today, that's more important than ever.
Grossman's tenure
has not been without controversy.
After firing thousands of workers
over Zoom calls during the pandemic,
she and her team faced a
raft of public criticism.
They literally just said,
I'm gonna be reading from a script.
You will not be able to speak.
The women say it was all over
after just three minutes.
I had never been fired before.
So here I am, 66 years old.
Grossman defended the decision
as part of the company's
inevitable digital slimming down.
We have made the decision
to accelerate our efforts,
particularly in digital and virtual.
And unfortunately that had us make
the very difficult decision
that affected a number of
employees around the world.
This past year was brutal
for so many businesses.
You had to lay people off.
You faced criticism for
the way that you did that.
Like, how does that feel in the moment
and how do you sort of
keep that North Star?
Look, no one enjoys, right,
when people are coming at you
for something you've done.
But the way I think
about it is any decision
that I've ever had to make
that affects anyone in any way
is a very carefully humane decision.
Now we came into the year
with the greatest momentum
the company's ever had,
and then the world shifted.
And we had to make the
decision to close our offices
and pause every one of
our physical workshops.
But we trained 14,000 coaches and guides
and simultaneously launched
all those workshops virtually
in 12 different markets.
So the learnings from
that have now created
a whole new opportunity for us.
Grossman had a not-so-secret
weapon to deploy
when it came to WW, Oprah.
The woman who taught the world how to feel
and has publicly struggled
with her own weight
took a stake in WeightWatchers in 2015
and became an ambassador and board member.
Hanging out with Oprah all the time
is probably most people's wildest dream.
But also, I would think, at
least this is me talking,
I'd be a little intimidated.
How do you manage a
relationship with Oprah
and sort of get the best
that you can out of yourself
and out of Oprah?
One thing you have to know about Oprah,
you have to know about Oprah,
she is so diligent and specific
about what she will do
and what she won't do.
And it's the things that you say no to
that actually really define you.
So anything she does is purposeful.
And what I realized is that we both saw
the same opportunity for this brand
that had actually been transforming
lives for so many years,
but now in a new generation,
we could be so much more.
As the world started to realize
the extent of the COVID-19 pandemic,
Grossman was on the road with Oprah,
firing up arena-sized crowds
with their shared vision
of a new kind of health and wellness,
powered of course, by WW.
Are there some days
where you look at
yourself and you go, damn?
Even COVID couldn't stop the momentum.
With WW offices
and its network of retail
locations shuttered
as the world quickly went remote.
Hey, everybody!
Grossman's team created a four-week
free virtual tour of
sorts starting in May.
When we had to make that pivot
when the pandemic happened--
Yes!
Within a few weeks we launched
a virtual tour led by Oprah
and we made it available for
free to everyone globally.
I see you all look very good up top,
but no telling what you
got down on the bottom.
And at some point,
we all gonna have to
put real pants on again,
and we're gonna hope they fit.
That's what I'm doing, right?
So speaking of board members, Mindy,
one of the other people I
was able to catch up with
was Julie Rice, who I know has become
a friend of yours of late, but
that wasn't always the case.
And so I actually asked her
how you guys met originally.
So I want you to check this out.
Julie is so great.
I can't wait to, okay.
Back when I was opening
my second SoulCycle
on East 83rd Street, I
was a new entrepreneur
and two mutual friends of Mindy's called
and said that they were gonna be bringing
Mindy Grossman to a class.
Somebody like Mindy was
a full-blown celebrity.
I couldn't think of a celebrity
that I would rather have come
ride at SoulCycle than Mindy.
I mean, I remember prepping
the front desk with flowers
and making sure that I got
there early to make a sort of
a perfect little swag
bag for her to take home.
And I met her and she came
and she took the class.
And the whole time she was in class
I was just thinking to myself,
gosh, I hope she likes this.
I just remember her being so tuned in
to what we were trying to create there.
And when a good girlfriend of mine
sent me a text and she said,
Mindy Grossman is going
to run WeightWatchers.
That is something that you
should try to get in on.
And so honestly, I stalked her.
I sent her a note.
We hadn't spoken in years.
I had no idea if she would remember me,
and sure enough she got back to me
within the next hour or so.
And she said, I'd love to.
Do you want to have a cup of
coffee in the next week or so?
That's sort of how our friendship began.
And then ultimately I
wound up joining the board
and I learn sitting next to her.
I learn about being a better leader.
I learn that the idea of not
innovating is scarier sometimes
then shaking the whole thing up.
I would just say that
Mindy is really brave
and really innovative.
Oh.
Well, it sounds like she wasn't gonna stop
until you guys were like, well-connected.
I would not get in her way.
The one thing she and I have in common
is an insatiable sense of curiosity.
And when we see something
or want to do something,
we'll put ourselves out there.
And I've kind of been
known to stalk people too,
if I really want to learn more
or be able to have a conversation.
To go, how did you do that?
Or why did you do that?
If you're more curious,
you're going to be more diverse
in your thinking in general.
And so surrounding myself
with people like Julie
and other members of our board
is one of the most valuable
things that I, or we could do.
You know, so Mindy, it's
interesting to interview,
and I'll say this as like
a middle-aged white man
asking you this.
We strive so much to talk about,
it's not a male CEO or a
female CEO, it's just a CEO.
And yet you have been a
trailblazer by all accounts.
I know a lot of women look up to you.
So what advice are you giving
to women who are coming up?
So I would say a couple of things.
Number one is I believe the
reason I've been successful
is I have focused my career
on making other people successful.
Because if I do that, they
will be more successful,
the business will be more successful,
and ultimately I will be more successful.
The second thing is self-awareness
is your greatest superpower.
You need to truly understand your behavior
and its impact on others.
And know everything about yourself,
whether it's the good,
the bad and the ugly.
And know how you need to
show up to motivate people.
The third thing is
progress, not perfection.
I think too many women have felt
that they don't put themselves out there
because they have to wait to be perfect.
And I think I make
people open up their eyes
when I say I don't believe
I've truly been 100% ready
for any job I've ever taken.
But I've always defined
myself as a transformer
with the ability to create
positive change around business,
positive change around impact.